[Music]
good morning Hank it's Monday August
20th and somebody needs a haircut hint
it's me it's the weirdest thing Hank
you're walking around for a couple weeks
and you're thinking you should probably
get a haircut in the next week or so you
know just kind of preventive medicine
kind of haircut and then one day you
wake up and you're like oh right this is
what they called me muffin head in
middle school
hey I can't tell you how grateful I am
that we never attended the same middle
school at the same time because frankly
I don't think you could have handled the
shame
I got a very interesting piece of news
our secret brother Tom used a machine
that involves some magic and a lawnmower
in order to calculate the midpoint
between you and Missoula and me and
Indianapolis and it turns out that the
midpoint between us is a town called
winter South Dakota winter South Dakota
Hank as in the opposite of loser South
Dakota anyway Hank I got to thinking
that you and me and the nerdfighters
could potentially pool our resources and
purchase the town of winner South Dakota
and then build a kind of nerdfighting
calm you know two things about the
hypothetical nerdfighter communal the
buildings would be made out of
sustainable materials and number two
everyone would sleep in race car beds so
I went online to Wikipedia to see
whether or not winner South Dakota is
small enough for us to potentially
consider purchasing Hank according to
Wikipedia wiki wiki wiki wiki pedia
winner South Dakota has a population of
just over 3,000 people it's located in
south-central South Dakota which is
exactly like South Central Los Angeles
except different in every possible way
also according to Wikipedia winner South
Dakota has a fascinating history Hank
I'm going to read this to you and I
swear I'm not making it up no one knows
the exact date that winner became winner
some claim to know but they are liars
the territory where men are now resides
was first discovered by white people in
1726 when French fur trader and magician
Jean Pierre Sebastian alla kyng crossed
the Missouri River on his infamous
search for the elusive non-existent
giant red footed prairie beaver of the
Dakotas although a terrible fur trader
and magician Jean Pierre managed to make
a fortune in the canned chicken and
biscuit industry before dying the
botulism
in 1743 Oh Wikipedia will you ever tell
me true
facts Hank another news if you noticed
all the amazing things the nerdfighters
have been doing lately nerdfighter
sad-sack is designing awesome
nerdfighter animations like this one
secret brother Todd created a fantastic
intro for all the secret siblings to use
we got a bunch of nerdfighters helping
to build the wiki wiki what wikki wikki
wikki plus we got hundreds of people
centered in nerdfighter pictures like
this and this and this and this and this
we got so many nerdfighters in my pants
that sometimes the site goes down Hank I
know you're working on that and I
appreciate it a group of nerdfighters
led by CR are starting a humiliation for
charity project that I think is awesome
plus Tobias is still rocking the songs
and all the old school nerdfighters are
doing a great job of integrating all of
the new school nerdfighters so that
everyone collectively finds that they
are made of more awesome than they ever
thought possible Hank I don't want to
exaggerate the effect that this project
is having on my life but it's sort of
starting to make me believe in humanity
again I find myself saying and thinking
outlandish ly optimistic things lately
like I'll be staring outside this
weather
and I'll say wow that's gonna be really
great for the plants I mean honestly
Hank this is really the first time when
I've started to feel like maybe the
world contains more nerdfighters than
nerd haters my entire life I've thought
that I was best suited for the town of
loser South Dakota but I'm starting to
change my mind I find myself thinking
maybe nerd fighting is for winners I'll
see you tomorrow